[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance are there tapes of Donald
Trump's White House meetings and phone
calls with James Comey and perhaps
others or are there not if there are
what do they say if there are not did
Trump destroy them it is now more than
five weeks since this issue was first
raised by naturally Trump tweeting his
mouth off may 12th Jemez Comey better
hope that there are no tapes of our
conversations before he starts leaking
to the press since then we have gotten
from Trump at his sycophants
misdirection obfuscation and cuteness
when it is for this man's presidency
life or death to either produce tapes
that validate his versions of
conversations with Comey and others or
to prove that tapes never existed in the
first place and thus he has not
destroyed possible evidence in a
criminal case there seem to be new
insight into this during the
wall-to-wall coverage given this past
Sunday of a part time radio host part
time guitarist full time Nathan therm
look-alike named Jay Sekulow mr. Sekulow
is one of trumps attorneys he is the man
who told Chris Wallace of Fox News that
the president was indeed being
investigated for firing Comey and then
in literally the next breath said no he
wasn't being investigated for firing
James Comey Sekulow also appeared the
same morning on CBS and NBC but it was
the CBS interview that actually mattered
the most of all three John Dickerson
asked the president said last week he
would release the tapes of if there were
tapes of his conversation this week that
hasn't happened where is that Sekulow
replied I think the president is going
to address that in the week ahead there
were a lot of issues this past week the
issue will be dressed in due course
and I suspect next week next week as of
June 19th being obviously this week
except don't count on that exactly a
week earlier Jay Sekulow was on ABC and
he said the same thing that's a decision
that the president will make in
consultation with his chief lawyer mark
Kassovitz said Sekulow adding Trump
would address it next week next week
as of June 12th now being obviously last
week suggesting that next week as of
June 19th actually means next week I'm
just going to say this next week part
again thus is the Trump gang continuing
to kick the can down the road on the
issue of just confirming or denying that
there are tapes as I have noted here
previously Trump has put himself in an
impossible position soon or late at an
impeachment or in a courtroom Trump will
need those tapes will need them to
validate his version and not commis if
he cannot produce them he will either be
asking us to believe he would not
release something that would exonerate
him or he will have to confess that his
tweet of May 12th was an empty threat or
worst of all he will have to prove that
there aren't tapes that there never were
tapes and that he did not destroy tapes
and frankly I do not know how you ever
prove that vast a negative just to put a
timeframe to this the House Intelligence
Committee had given Trump until this
Friday to voluntarily turn over any
tapes there are two known potential
outside sources for Trump tapes or at
least information about Trump tapes the
Secret Service says it does not have any
this was in reply to a Freedom of
Information Act request by The Wall
Street Journal then there is the
long-standing assumption that for
security reasons all phone calls to the
White House no matter who the president
is are automatically recorded in case
somebody makes a threat is that true is
it also done for outgoing calls if there
are recordings are they kept is there a
tape of the March 30th call in which
Comey claims Trump talked about the
cloud he was under and pushed him to
publicly clear him about Russia is there
a tape of the April 11th call in which
Comey claims Trump wanted to know what
Comey had done about publicly clearing
him depending on the language used tapes
of either of those phone calls could be
submitted as evidence of Trump trying to
obstruct the FBI investigation and thus
to obstruct justice or even if Trump
threatening Comey or of him trying to
induce
only to lie we only know that the Secret
Service says they don't have any
recordings we only know that two weeks
ago Trump said we'd soon find out and be
disappointed by the answer we only know
that this goober Sekulow has now done on
talk shows on consecutive Sundays and
predicted resolution next week leading
me to wonder if Sekulow is now not in
fact an actual person but is himself
simply a recording but there is another
way to clear this up at least in part
and I hardly think I'm the first person
to realize this the big issue of
recordings and the little ones of who
does or does not have them White House
operations
Secret Service Trump himself can be
ascertained by the Justice Department's
Special Counsel
using a little technical device known
inside the world of audio and inside
other worlds as a quote subpoena and
lastly there is one other possibility
that to my surprise I haven't seen
raised anywhere else in the District of
Columbia it is legal to record
conversations in person or on the phone
so long as one of the people in the
conversation knows it is being recorded
down the block from Ford's Theater just
before you get to that chopped salad
place at its office then the FBI record
all the phone calls that come in to its
headquarters I mean never mind
Trump Comey tapes are there could there
be legally can there be
FBI Comey tapes resist piece